これを言う時が来たか
まずであんまり人に言ってなかったんですけど
ただ最近ふとスター会話の中で思い出すたというかもうほぼ忘れてたんですけど
変化別にも隠すことでもないんであの動画にしようかなと思って動画にしております
こんにちははじめ社長です
タイトルにもあるとおりでございます
始め殺王は
女性になりたい
わけじゃないんですけどクセになりたいわけではないんですけど
むしろ男性を楽しんでいるところがあります男でよかったと思っています
僕の中では一つの人生のイベントというか大きな事件だったんですけども
まあそんななんかオーボエ話ではないんですただこういうことがあったなというか普通
の人は経験しないんだろうなということで今回話させていただきます
本当にタイトルにある通りであの女性か
したことが私でありましてちゃんと調べてないとわからないですけども明らかに彼らの
に自然があったきっかけはですね僕が
21歳から22歳ぐらいかな
二十一二十二ぐらいの時にあの僕も男性なんで市議が入るんですね
ヒゲが生えるってこの顔あの見てわかると思うんですけども日が似合わないんですよ
金曜流行ったと不潔になるような顔なんですごい
ヒゲに悩んだ図1があったんですぼく
21人くらいから二十歳からちょっとひげが生え始めてめっちゃヒゲに悩んだ時期が
あったんですよ
でそれが僕の中で大きな悩みになっててまぁ当然そんなお金もないですし
脱毛っていうものもあまり流行ってなくて今はもちろんの脱毛したんであのヒゲは
かなり生えなくなったんですけども
当時はその立つもうしてるメンズっていうのはあんまり効かなかった時代で本当にして
たい人はもちろんいらっしゃるんですけどもなんかそんな一般的に結構やる人が多いっ
て感じでもなくてお金もすごい高かったですして当時の僕には全然できなかったんです
けどでもすごい悩んだって自分で調べたんですよネットとかでヒゲを薄くする方法とか
なんかいろいろ子調べていろんな方法を試したんですけども
たどり着いたのはですねなんでヒゲが入るのっていうの原因
員を調べようと思って釣られた結果まあいろんな諸説あるんですけども男性ホルモ
男性ホルモンが多いと肘が生えてくるとかなら体毛が濃くなるという話を聞いてあ
男性ホルモンになった
思って
[音楽]
思って男性ホルモンが原因かと確かに女性で濃いヒゲ生えてるイメージあんまりないな
と思ってそのホルモンの問題安いんですよ
兄がポイントかヒゲが生えるとかってデー
服なりに本当に悩んでて顔に似合わずに沿ってもすぐ入るしどうすればいいんだと調べ
たときに女性ホルモン
いいみたいな話を聞いてイソフラボンって皆さんご存知でしょうか
大豆製品に含まれる成分なんですけども急ぐらぼん豆腐とかね豆乳とかそういうふうに
含まれている磯それを持って西武があるんですけどそれを調べて磯ドラゴンという成分
が
女性ホルモンと同じような働きをする成分なんですよなんで僕はもうひげを薄くしたい
の一心で豆乳飲みまくり
た舞踏つ動画だしてだね投入混ぜて飲む動画を出してたかもしれない
豆腐を食べまくり豆乳を飲みまくり急ぐらぼん
大豆製品を撮りまくって何とか女性ホルモンに似た働きを入れて毛を薄くしようって
頑張ったんですけどもイマイチ効果がなくてで
もうどうしようもないなと思ったんですけどネットで調べていたら
あったんですよ女性ホルモンにかなり似た働きをするなら薬みたいなやつがちょっと
詳しい話は覚えてないですちょっともないし軍だけですけどこ切りやすいプラセンタ
だけそういうのも飲んでたんですよ何かさんあの違法じゃないですよ
違法じゃないんですけどもちゃんと売られている女性ホルモンに似た働きをしてくれる
サプリみたいなやつが売ってて
これだなと僕の肘を薄くする方法はもう
[音楽]
第税日のことってでも間に合わんこれも専用なサプリを飲むしかないということでその
サプリを飲み始めたわけです
でしたのーさっぱりー薬を飲み始めたんですけどもなんか自分で言うのもあれですけど
も何かの間だったら僕それをこなすためだったらなんでもしちゃうんでその理由の
わからなさぷりをちゃんと何いつ飲み続けたんです一日も忘れず来る日も来る日も
そんなサプリをの3つ
受けもうひげを薄くしたいその一心でそのサプリを食べて食べて用法用量を守り
ちょっと適量摂取し続けたんですけども
ある日気づいたんですよ胸が大きくなっていることに
こがっちです
このあの恥ずかしくうううう56あれば僕ガリガリだったんですよめっちゃカリカリで
も胸なんかにお肉乗ることない
もう鎖骨がー見えてるくらいの細い体だったのにそんなサプリを摂り始めてから体が
何か
柔らかくなってきたというかふくよかな感じになってきて
胸もなんかふっくらしてきたんですかマジで本当に本当に彼らのネタとかじゃないです
よまずですよ
ふっくらしてきてうん
女性ホルモン
かちょっとは勘のいいんですけどもボタンは女性ホルモンでしょうね同じような働きを
してるって書いてあったんで女性ホルモンが降りたからか分からないんですけどガチで
おっぱいがちょっとふっくらしてきてああであれまあ女になっちゃうみたいな感じに
なったんですよ2123よと聞いてなんかしこりみたいな届きと言ってたんですよ
がちですよこりごりするものができて
したりしてなんか怖くて調べたら確かすごいの塊だったか忘れないんですけど本当に
おっぱいが3等地とふっと出てきてあのマジで一時期女性がし初めてのついてがあり
ました
そんなことなんだな自分でも強かったですね
俺男じゃなくなるのかなと思ってさすがにセグやめたんですけどさすがにこれは何か
ヤバイ気がしてきたのを止めた瞬間胸がすっとまた補足戻ったんですよ本当に
これもバランスが変わってそうなったのかなという感じだったんですけどほんと一瞬
だけちょっと
必ず女性化し始めてきていた咳がありました
冗談抜きで肝心のひげ
はどうなったかと言いますとホルモンバランスの乱れによって毛深くなったりする
らしいんですよ男性ホルモンも多いとか女性よりも多いとか関係なくホルモンバランス
の乱れによってたい方が濃くなることがありますけどで結果的に僕はおっぱいが出てき
て火木がめっちゃ濃くなっただけでした
あっは
[音楽]
clar